there are plenty of impressive esports
records out there most money earned most
headshots secured in fact we literally
just did a video about that one but some
records are a little weirder shall we
say the kind of records that don't get
celebrated because most people don't
even know they exist but before we get
into that we want to tell you all about
a brand new series that has just
launched on our channel we've teamed up
with cisco to bring you every second
counts a new series that will see us
break down some of the biggest plays in
esports history we've just released our
very first episode you can find the link
to that in the description box below and
now without further ado let's jump into
our list of the top 10 weirdest esports
records
kicking off our list is simple who is
without a doubt a one in a billion
generational talent
[Music]
especially when it comes to cs go
effecto and simple he needs a multi-kill
first found twist aggressing they have
to double peek he's getting his shots
he's hitting another one simple oh
simple that's unbelievable what in his
name number one in the game he's done it
again the man has 16 mvp titles to his
name has set multiple records including
most kills in an fpl match has been on
hltv's top 20 players list several times
even taking the number one spot in 2018
you get the picture but even though
simple has made it to the final stages
of a major twice he has never actually
won cs go's most prestigious award
despite monstrous individual
performances on different rosters
would you really quit he has to play
well around
listen
if i was astralis that want four majors
i would probably think about this you
know
besides i have
zero major
i'll keep going
now that's got to be some kind of record
speaking of great players who never seem
to win when it matters and number nine
pick is double lift i don't want to just
win an lcs i want to win worlds and i
hope people
will remember me as
one of the first north american world
champions
so why did i come back
i came to win between the inception of
the lcs in 2011 and his retirement
doublelift only ever missed seasons
three and four and he currently holds
the record for attending worlds eight
times the most of any pro league player
ever and winning zero and since he
retired from pro play in 2020 that
record will basically stand until
there's a player unfortunate enough to
do the same thing at least nine times
goals i guess
our eighth entry a round of cs go play
between mouse sports and faze during an
esl pro league match can only be
described as comically short
attempted a comeback there but mouse was
able to shut them down and now malz
looks like they're going to be taking
the half ahead
keep in mind this map can go t sided oh
no it's the rush up middle eco push
i did not want to see that guy since
that is that was tough that's like
watching adults beat up children
lasting a total of 8.38
seconds faze's ill-fated full eco
attempt to rush mid holds the record for
the shortest recorded big event round in
pro cs go history reportedly contested
only by a seven second round between
crazy and nordovin in european and minor
qualifiers other short rounds came close
but so far the absurd length of phases
sprint into a hail of bullets remains
pretty much unmatched
self-sacrifice is a noble thing just ask
dota 2's milk the namesake of the
ultimate taking 1 or 20 for the team
award that sits at the number seven spot
on our list mel died 20 times and got
zero kills in a semi-finals match
between eg and mouse sports and his team
still won on fear my cast wants to go in
for a black hole as well but not enough
people are there and the first one to
die is milk
okay
it's fun
it's it's great they have their fun we
won the game everyone wins the meme was
created the community wins from there
any player who died 20 times or more and
killed no one in a match was the
unofficial recipient of the milk award
as long as they weren't intentionally
feeding a goddamn hero
esports are generally considered a
youthful pursuit but there are of course
exceptions and our sixth entry the
silver snipers are proving that cs go
isn't just for the kiddies
when the team won their world
championship title in senior cs the
oldest player on the team was 78 years
old bernie tries to stray through the
door and gets down ullah
so if grandma and grandpa can do it
what's your excuse
at number five now we have the virtus
pro challenge a fun summit seven run by
vp that saw the team use almost every
champion available in dota 2. cool
tournament for them it was fun to watch
it was fun to witness a bunch of new
heroes and then game five taking it back
and saying hey we're here to win and uh
coming through with the victory vp used
80 different heroes throughout the
course of 17 games and ended up winning
the entire event showing everyone that
they weren't just one of the best teams
to ever grace dota 2's competitive
stages but also one of its most creative
coming in at number four is a tournament
so massive the number of participants
eclipsed the population of some
countries at least seven million people
signed up to participate in online
qualifiers for the 2017 fifa interactive
world cup now just to put that in
context that's all of tennessee or
bulgaria for the europeans watching the
entire qualifying process took nearly a
year as they whittled down the field to
a grand finals of just 32
[Music]
and join us competitors that was a very
special moment for that boy
ryan hart the fighting game champ
extraordinaire takes the third spot on
our list with his official guinness
world record for the most consecutive
opponents beat in street fighter 5. the
man literally spent 11 hours straight
whooping ass in 260 matches and he only
really needed a 90 win rate to take the
record but ended up plowing through
absolutely everyone he went up against
and while that's more impressive than
weird you have to admit the level of
concentration you'd need to do something
like this is unusual but according to
the man himself the record was just one
long learning opportunity for all of his
260 opponents if you're just winning and
not learning there's no progress
happening and it probably just and the
sad truth with that is it probably just
means your opponents are not good
yeah because to get better you need to
learn by losing
we've talked about scream and his
penchant for headshots many times before
but the actual most lethal man in cs go
isn't picky about which body part he
aims for kenny s comes in with a double
at number two with records for the most
overall career and orb kills in the game
over 36 and 19 000 respectively could
happen here good read frank there's
kenny dropping the bomb oh what a
beautiful repeat goes for another one
and he's shutting it all down kenny s is
one bloodthirsty man
teddy's mind-blowing cs record takes the
number one spot now on our list back in
2018 jin air green wings the middle of
the pack team known for being shockingly
strong in long games faced off against
skt in a 94 minute mammoth of a match as
it happened teddy was playing sivir a
champion notorious for her wave clearing
abilities yeah i just tell my teammates
whether it's the truth or a lie i'll
just hard carry them and carry them to a
victory that's what i tell them always
and they seem to trust me enough that
they will uh bloat me with all the css
available now up until that game the cs
record would have been broken pretty
regularly but after the
uncharacteristically long match with a
minion chomping champion on a team that
thrived on extended battles at 1
465 cs for teddy we now have a number so
absurdly high the record is honestly
unlikely to ever be broken
okay that's it for our weirdest esports
records i found those pretty weird but
maybe you were watching that and
thinking there's some way weirder
records out there if you do know of some
then do let us know maybe we'll make a
part two i'm sure there's plenty of
other weird records out there thanks for
watching guys and i'll see you all in
the next one
you